ome hearties it's Wednesday afternoon
and welcome to your international talk
like a pirate
edition of the Android developer office
hours emea edition are drinking your
your first mate here we're here to we
here to talk about anything and
everything related to Android
development so rich do you want to give
you a standard disclaimer yes questions
asked in a pirate fashion will be taking
twice as seriously as any other
questions we're wearing a professional
matching t-shirts by accident it's
certainly not planned and we won't be
talking about any future values product
releases and prevent anything that
hasn't been previously announced so
please don't ask I got quite a few
people in the Hangout was just dead I'm
just run through i'll say hello wow good
see you here hey guys yeah cuz I Andrew
Kelly next outcome have a little cursor
over yeah Kendrick and it on my
moderator machine good see is the next
one hi mark as well you seem to know
stuff you already poor Richard Thompson
Sparky of course and tough see you up so
before we kick off into the moderator
today I'll see I'm here with Matt and
you must know these guys oh I does
anyone here yeah have any questions yeah
yeah go to the start yeah yeah sure
let's go Freddie's do okay no okay well
then how's dark maybe um yeah last
question baby and about the assets
assets for the library projects I
already asked that on the moderator
regarding the inheritance of the assets
because we have some like for example
sunbae fuse just some HTML files and
some graphics or PNG files not fancy
stuff and we have for example the
library project with common HTML files
and common
images and now we need to always copy
these assets over to the final projects
in order to get the stuff down but I
think this would be a really nice thing
to let the SDK tools do that do it
because it's plain simple just copy the
essence over and do a simple inheritance
and I'm just asking white and there
because it's so an easy feature in my
opinion I think it's because assets are
you did there it does it's a folder
location and its relative to the driver
space occasion if you if you read the
documentation carefully it says that
although raw assets are not supported
for library projects that raw resources
are so anything you drop into rest right
side row should be okay I mean there's
really you know they're apart from a
minor API difference on how you access
it there's not a lot of difference
between how you deal with a raw resource
versus an asset resource I had a quick
look around on this one and there is a
place from savvier from the adg team and
basically what it says is he's not come
up with enough time to work on an
intelligent solution for collisions
between assets are in the library
project and assets which are in your
actual application project so i think
it's just one of those things that's on
the list and just hasn't been got around
to yet okay that would be a good
explanation because it's I don't know
where there are so many collisions so
for example yet the order of the library
projects defined and you're also the
inheritance of the library projects
defined and I think because it's just a
simple folder with files of it you could
just copy them over in the right order
in the end you're done basically I don't
know what they really mean with these
complex collisions the problem comes if
any of the libraries require on an asset
of a certain name and a third library
further up the chain uses that same name
for a different type of asset you then
get undefined behavior in one of your
libraries because it doesn't know it's
not getting the correct asset under that
name so if you have a chat project that
has a list called
blar and something else that has a
graphic called blah you'll find your
chat library gets a graphic instead of
the list it expects and probably will
throw our errors that you shouldn't
normally say okay sounds convincing to
me and yeah I know we could just do this
in the bog resources and I'm Batman and
done but basically you can't access the
wall resources so in west wall with the
web view which is really plain awful and
also if you do HTML pages it's a little
bit harder you know in the in the SS
folder you can just load the web you
called file / / assets and so on and
then you can just load the html5 and it
loads the images automatically at the
end you're done and the other way round
you would have to yeah it's basically
playing harder to do this with the wall
resources instead of using SS for this
case if you want a quick and dirty hack
you can use a class in a library file
that actually just contains the string
which is the HTML you want to render in
the web gear I know I know this is
basically what I want to do now but its
place basically a hack to get the assets
in the correct well that's not a really
friendly to your workflow is it i'll put
a link to the adt group in the in the
comments for this hangout post and then
even join and see if there's anything
that those guys can do for you in order
to get things sped up and getting your
solution ok great or another workout is
what expending on your field system v
script it may be so it moves yes I since
the right place for you argue build so
what now we have the antibiotics and
alpha and we just have our project and
then every project we copy over the
first s folder from one library project
and the second hasn't folder third one
basically what the sdk tools should be
doing is any second manually copy the
more you advise your aunt Belva we
manually copy them in how and built
that of course now the problem is the
Eclipse eggy the APK file built from the
jacobs build server and the eclipse epic
a philosopher and it's not so easy to
get the application out of eclipses with
the correct staff so why not we do it
manually yeah so basically that's what
we're doing but yeah could be much
easier with some sdk tools update i also
had viewed them there were some patches
online and garrett before the transition
to the new garrett server and there was
a purchase online doing exactly this so
enabling the sdk tools but nobody
reviewed them yet so it's not in there
yet are they in the new Garrett or are
they still just in the old Garrett I
think it wasn't the old guard you might
want to see who submitted them and ask
them to resubmit them to the new Garrett
because I think the old Garrett's been
pretty much abandoned now no no okay
yeah basically I will all do the the
hacking for now but could be easier also
for other developers okay so everyone
line questions in the Hangout or should
we move on to the moderator I think
we've got some more questions on the
moderator from people who are in the
Hangout Paul is this yours about the
loaders do you want to ask that question
I will yes but I no microphone okay so
so Paul London Liverpool wants to know
loaders seem to be the new in thing to
use when developing an app can we
explain the use cases and some of the
benefits of using a loader over the
alternative mmm anybody want to take
that one should i take it basically the
the cool thing about loaders is it's the
it's the simplest way to keep the
contents of your view in sync with its
data source so like back before loaders
you had to actually watch
for for callbacks and events regarding
whether or not your data had changed and
been updated and now the lawyers will
take care of that for you so you make a
list view or a list fragment and you you
implement the the loader interface and
you say you have a content provider
that's feeding data into that loader you
stuff something new into the content
provider unless your list view just
magically updates and you never have to
worry about callbacks or a
synchronization or anything like that
but we want to add anything to that the
life cycle events as well I think it
kind of really implementable with the
life cycle so it handles all your causes
and resumes for you I will reconnect the
data source and what good for any
changes so essentially you write this
code it did a lot of hope of people all
that stuff life cycle stuff for you so
there's less to maintain a debug I
thought they're also very good for
making sure your data was loaded off the
main thread as well so what happens in
the background out of the main thread
and keeps your application you I ran
nice and smoothly whilst the loadings
happening as opposed to your clothes
Melissa this have been talking about is
this specific to the cursor loader
concrete class but it's also the load of
framework is more generic seating you
could extend they sink to loader to do
other stuff like this as well which
isn't just a totally melted and you
still benefit from olney and the
framework integration as well to me
there has also been a bit okay Paul is
oh you're a nice one he says i'm
convinced i will use lovers from now on
thanks guys what's up when we want to
jump in I don't want to jump another
question someone just came on Johan do
you have a question for us you have the
microphone so we can hear ye mete it yet
it's very good for only money right yeah
that's all that I did on I won't know
okay hi guys just want to say hi I don't
have any particular
seeing I'm wrestling with well maybe I
was thinking about one thing for engaged
I have something like a dialogue with
with small selection of course you know
that there are some context menus or
smaller how you say it what's the budget
term but maybe small dialog switch with
hang to a component in at your little
section of choices of course you have to
our left a big pop up views what's kind
of the way to go I'm tend to simply go
with with the default selection list
mechanism context about coma clinic you
give you a little context about what you
watch my show well it's basically I have
a couple of buttons on the on screen and
if I press a button they're still a sub
selection to be done before you go to
the next activity so I'm kind of
figuring out what what's the best way to
go there if I simply have a small pop-up
menu which kind of hangs to that button
and I think you had the context the
quick context is maybe a bit so what i
was looking at so what's what's what's
the current design guideline on those
kind of contextual pop-ups i would avoid
a pop-up if possible yeah in line so
it's fine see you know you care button
and it reveals another choice but
knowing how that would work fine yeah
the pop-up menu which you're talking
about which is kind of similar to the
overflow menu you know where you hit a
button in it and it expands now that's
also a good option another option could
be to just kind of move on to the next
action and default it's one of the
choices and allow the users have change
to the other choice you don't so i think
just try and avoid these modal dialogues
is generally a good okay sounds fair I
think I go with it to simply choose one
of the options in and go for a selection
for the other options thank so much oh
yeah
great work with the other ones yeah I
was good fun what's good from maybe you
didn't tell us a little bit about it for
those who worked with you yeah yeah if
you have some time I'll keep short a
couple of user groups have found out
that androids five years old so was
introduced why it was introduced on
fifth of November in 2007 and a couple
of user groups in in Europe in the world
I picked it up and we're trying to
celebrate with a series of exons around
Europe so we have one in Amsterdam and
one in Bremen but there's still a couple
of of hackathons in Belgium and in
Berlin and Paris it i think is also
joining an Ankara and a couple of others
and so we add the the first in Amsterdam
with a couple of teams simply hacking
away in a couple of categories defined
by the International work group and and
other cities are joining in as well and
there's one big finale in London right
of the droid phone where we will have a
well all the all the winners from the
local hackathons they are competing with
the team from the UK so if you are
living in the UK you have a kind of
advantage you can simply join the final
really now it's going to be good fun
with with great prices where we got to
get and give away some devices from out
there so it's pretty good everybody
walked away with the tablet or a phone
so everybody had a good time where's the
best place planet more people when it
went in I think it's simply V heck
Android dork I'll put it in the chip
thank you very much hope instead thanks
to the summary sounds like an awesome
hot 100 Spencer under one yeah all of us
will be that yeah you're great fun ok I
wasn't good to have to go get back to
work so on headphone and spa key have
fun on the oktoberfest of course no
Thank You chef so type of it is have a
good beer maybe we see each other there
so by I listened so anybody else I see
we've got Andrew Kelly on the on the
line I I think you've got maybe a
question or two in the moderator did you
want to ask those yourself ya don't mind
and let me just bring up the page I
guess the first one was to do with
taking pictures with the camera I was
having some trouble getting the photos
to be stored in a private area my app
rather than on the SD card I was just
wondering if there's any special trick
that I needed to do together to happen
now you take another you want to put him
in an internal storage yes I honestly
never tried to do that I think there's a
problem with trying to do that because
the camera is a separate application so
any areas would be able to would have to
write it would have to be a publicly
writable of area there is but you can
actually pass when you launch the intent
a permission to say you can inherit the
permissions of the sort of parent app so
I was thinking that that might give the
camera app permission to write to my
private storage like it's not to make
the file we're all right able I think
the grant permission just grants
permission to read that I think you
grant me congrats of like anything
living yeah there's two there's a
there's a grant to writing a grant to
read you all right you check the stock
though they don't see to it and there's
no help on Stack Overflow on that one no
not really can ask the question that's
why I came to you guys yeah I think
every example that I've seen just rates
to the SD card because that's the
standard media repository you know I so
yeah I don't want people to speak with
the pictures that they're taking once
they've taken in spirit
I'm writing now you can I mean if you if
you only want a small picture you could
you could get a thumbnail back and just
not store it yeah in fact a little at my
little demo app does that here now I
have to say I'm after the big picture
I'm afraid what about taking the photo
and copying it or looting it yeah that
was that was my sort of last resort I
was trying to if there is no other way
ah solution but if there is a I haven't
used this kind of a grand grand right
information before if that's not working
for you maybe and as a link to step fo
question we can take a look into it
further yes cool and one else use the
grant write permissions no very meaty
case trust me to find it you have any
more questions things like this than
what we've modeled to a couple of words
one about setting the wallpaper and I
was hoping to not have to request the
permission to set a wallpaper in just
Ashley soft launch the wallpaper intent
somehow and have be able to pass an
image to that that the user can then say
yes or no and is that something that's
possible oh no no no I've like you need
to send them to the wallpaper tutor or
you can use the intent but you can't
combine the two yes so I can register to
be one of the icons inside the wallpaper
chooser but i still cannot need the set
wallpaper permission to do setting as
far as i know i've never seen anyone yet
does a bit like to work around of
securities me yeah well i was going to
think of the right be a way that the
wallpaper choose there when i launched
yeah i set the image in there sort of on
results oh and then the wallpaper to
zurich and then do something with that
image like show to the user or whatever
if your app is trying to set wallpapers
why don't you just go and use the
permission
well i was watching my google i/o
produce your number of commissions a
video but we would ride where explicit
about the actions you were going to do
as opposed to working around them to try
and hide the permission well if you
happen i'm not trying to hide though I'm
trying to be puppy a sort of a summary
receiver of the intense for hey I'm just
one of the things as well as the sort
the live wallpaper gallery my app also
can show you a list of images that may
become from Flickr or somewhere like
that you choose the image from my stream
and then it's up to you to say set
wallpaper as it user to make it turn
into the background yeah so rather than
the kind of circumvent I was just trying
to alleviate the need for me to actually
have the set permission but you've tried
it doesn't work I take it without the
risk yeah in the source of wallpaper
list yes my love that new wallpapers
gallery right yeah that's pretty sick
yeah so I mean I'm in that list but I
still need to set wallpaper me
permission to to set the wallpaper me
not the impression I got make the i/o
talking last charm refused to
permissions you need in terms of ones
that you actually require vs ones that
you're just doing is a nice to have I
mean like AdMob is a prime example I'm
not yeah because I'm advertising it
would make a lot of sense but it's up to
you as our development to allow that or
not and yeah I think game to the worst
for that there are some games other we
should ask for a roofing amount for
missions that really on me do so i think
the end of day you've got a perfect kind
of use case for its I don't think any
user would sit there see their
permission and kind of run away scared
so that that's the main thing cool okay
regardless of whether you're registered
to be in that list you still I would
have the ability to set wallpapers right
yes I've got a button inside my app that
when you're viewing a photo you can
click that button that it says neo set
wallpaper and it just sets in the
background so when you actually exit the
app so your paper is
there yep yeah fair enough but no we
don't go away not do it all okay yep
that's question yeah I'm good hey Ronen
Lucy into the Hangout okay how are you
doing making Rick I guess I could see
that thanks both of us together it's
going to enjoyed it as well yeah we're
good wicked yeah actually I got a couple
of questions if you guys have time
please I one should be pretty easy i'm
trying to do audiomanager set microphone
muted the microphone problem is that API
works on some devices and doesn't work
on other devices and other than try and
see and check on all devices i don't
know how can i tell in advance and what
device will work on what and what api
should i use how the device is on the
same company always the different come
you know the same company as one device
that works in others that don't I can
tell you that on my galaxy s2 it doesn't
work on a Galaxy Nexus it doesn't work
on a galaxy s3 it does work on some HTC
that we've tested it works I can do a
whole list i don't have the list right
here front of me but some devices work
on some it didn't on the galaxy s2 the
US model it works just fine the european
model it doesn't work um things like
that i can see the link let me see what
what they're saying it stack overflow
there's a one of the answers there which
is an interesting one which is
simulating a mute button on
handset being pressed yeah I see that
it's just that works or it's unfortunate
that the it's also interesting it
doesn't work on the Galaxy Nexus which
is my big surprise yeah i went i would
probably draw a distinction between
muting moving the input for an
application versus muting input for
phone call as well i think that anytime
you're talking about a telephony stream
it just gets that much more complicated
well i'm not talking about the telephone
is trim just trying to mute the
microphone I'm doing I'll jewelry code
well I'm doing it a sip voice over IP
phone call but that's my application and
it works on the on the media stream it
doesn't work on the telephone string
well wouldn't undertake it's a cleaner
what I wouldn't Android think it's the
same thing whether it's a avoid call or
stun called same API which will
it's the same API we were talking about
the audio manager but first instead you
set the audio manager and audio stream
who work on what I was walling work on
well yeah when I am cyber was to meet
the volume at this yeah just the regular
volume but that there are some foam so
how did that doesn't work with and I'm
like shoot coming up when I was reading
about earlier and it doesn't really
matter whether it's a void call or
whether it's a start under code it's the
same patient same things so you're Oh as
far as for the android OS it doesn't
know that I'm doing avoid avoid cool my
application is doing all that stuff I'm
not using the android OS CP interface or
anything like that I'm just I just need
I opened the microphone to transfer the
immediate the LD packets i duel and G
729 compression all that stuff so as far
as for Android he doesn't know what I'm
doing with the audio de term i'm
recording gave you guys say that you
shouldn't be using this method Eddie so
the hack in the stack overflow question
to get the audio manager to the platform
audio managed to meet itself by
pretending to be a headset it actually
is reasonable the api doc said this
message should only be used by
applications that are replacing platform
white management of audio settings ok so
if you're replacing the entire audio
layer on the platform then maybe you can
use it because you're the only person
trying to control it i guess but
otherwise getting the I don't know if
there's another method to ask the
platform to be the microphone but faking
the handset mute which ask the platform
to really isn't it doesn't seem like a
bad solution it'd be interesting to have
a look into the source code for it and
see what it actually does and if you're
in control of what you do with your
history if using all the compression and
then sending it down your sip channel
can you just not send it if you hit
yeah that's that's a workaround I just
want to avoid that question because all
the the codec is done you know in MDK
it's done really down there and I want
the application to catch whether I'm
muted or not muted to display the right
user interface to the user stuff like
that if I don't have any choice then
yeah I will do it down during the codec
itself I will just ignore that
information i will not compress it in
our i will not have but I'm I'd rather
to have it done to do it just in the
application layer and first save logic
from the codec which is complex enough
as it is and again to be synchronized
with what to use this is if he sees his
microphone you to do not married and so
on um okay I guess there is no there is
no way easy path here which is quickly
in the suspects right um okay can I get
it now another one or is there somebody
else I've had a quick look in the source
code and basically the mute microphone
cools down to native code so i can vary
by platform okay so i have so i have to
implement a entire audio management
system for the entire system oh yeah
you're on string so you excited three
what is music yeah I'll look in Long
Point alright thanks and as always with
my Conover my first reaction right here
is platform-specific like the world's
one all right I think London just fell
yep they seem pretty frozen none i'm
still alive london drops off every now
and again yeah the the bridge is not
that strong sometimes have we got spa
yeah hey wait are you saying that London
Bridge is falling down are we are parted
in fact that they abused it really fast
quite surprisingly i'm gonna say the
next word of that song because calling
you my fair lady could be taken very
much Oh should we move on to do another
question the last I've got when we are
thinking about the way
the device and we are thinking on doing
a native versus the web if you see what
I meant web web view I mean to do it the
webview well to the Java html5 yeah read
mark zuckerberg comments I think that's
always need to engage yeah um actually
one of the Facebook guys just posted in
w3.org all the problems that they had
with html5 I can look up for a freight
if you want and you but one of the
biggest one seems to be the people right
html5 for mobile assuming that it's
going to be the same as the desktop and
I had the same processing power in it it
always fall short I it was like a
lottery for poor it's not a lot of
processing it's more like you know
acquiring information for me a silver
and basically showing it to the user
it's a it's not a big gap it's a smaller
but it's not a bit need to use a lot of
resources but it means you know they
want to make it fast and work on both
ways desktop and the mobile is unicast
use Java it was a bad way to my body if
you're talking about run fast but I
think maybe he means writing it fast
yeah I didn't they like developing
development type they needed a fast not
there to walk fast festa to work fast i
know i need native I you know I would
say for a quick and dirty first draft
you know see if it actually works yeah
go ahead use it with you um but I
wouldn't I wouldn't port a whole ton of
resources in Turin trying to make a
super good UI in a webview you know it's
like you just want basic form get little
data you display it but but don't don't
expect too much from it i would say okay
and what is the supply quen did webview
stuck in android versions which IP i did
it start phone
well make sure the same cabin it was it
was in one point naught so are they so
it doesn't clear him yeah that covers it
just want to make sure it's a
gingerbread in above that little
Brighton buff sense a ginger blood
hearts day actually my uh my little
little RSS reader sample that I threw
together last spring it runs all the way
back to 1.6 and I think it actually
works on on a g1 and it uses a webview
so reviews listed as being around since
API level one so it's a good safe bet
the only thing I'd say is it's a bit of
a risky path unless they're willing to
throw away the whole app if they want to
expand the functionality there's a
danger of starting off doing an html5
and then you end up with bits of organic
growth and you end up finding that
you've written a whole lap in html5 and
you hitting the performance barriers are
you turn out you've ever managed and say
I need to spend a month get back to
where they can see you already are up to
yeah yeah that's much why would I was
sort of careful to say you know don't
don't expect too much from your html5
version and don't pour too many
resources into trying to to gold pirate
I think one of the biggest risks as well
as it's very easy to sit there and
develop these sites on a desktop browser
and then kind of look at it on Chrome on
the mobile devices that no superformance
is ok carry on going and then when you
actually move it to a webview then
suddenly things start breaking it's
something that I've seen numerous people
do on the TV side and it's it's it's
kind of heartbreaking to see they get so
far then it just has to kind of stop and
have to go over everything it's exactly
the same that's it I suppose if if you
don't try to go to fancy with the html5
if you really stick to basic HTML not a
lot of JavaScript client side stuff no
there's there's a certain
the certain limit on how much damage you
can do it yourself and I limit you use
of CSS there's a lot of things you can
do in CSS to tend to be pretty process a
heavy these days well you know now
phones also getting faster so you need
to take that into consideration you know
it's quite funny that some phones out
better than some desktops now some
laptops but you ought to see the
statistics for the number of people
actually own phones like that they're
very limited and as you were saying
gingerbread phones predominant at the
moment they tend to be at least a
generation behind the current sort of
Ice Cream Sandwich and jelly bean folks
around well I guess when I skin will
become you know them
you
a bit more power but the other thing is
that there is always going to be need
for budget phones and people apply
budget phones so you're always going to
be fighting against that kind of friend
I mean you look at some of the other
companies in the the electronics space
and they figured out years ago that
basically at any given point in time
you've got certain price buckets that
people will buy from now say personal
computers you've got your under 500
bucks your thousand bucks your 2000-3000
and they will build the best device that
they can build to fit that price bucket
so you know no matter what you're always
going to have a phone maker who is going
to be trying to hit a fifty dollar price
per one hundred dollar price point and
so you know if you want if you want the
mass adoption of ice cream sandwich
you've got to get the hardware
capability at a run Ice Cream Sandwich
shrunk down to the point where you can
actually put it into a hundred-dollar
form factor mm-hmm the setting is 100
dolla phone I don't really know any of
those you know but that's what I
different a discussion actually that was
there's this was in the news maybe what
a year ago that there was a a line of
Android phones I think maybe gingerbread
that was being sold in in Kenya yeah
there was about 100 bucks baby well Bob
sized hundred bucks nyuk which is a
hundred pounds right said I was like
yeah the easy Huawei's yea trained up is
the T play range in Kenya for and $100
60 pounds it's a well I know here it's
quite a for example the HTC WhiteFire
you know the old one costs around what
is I think it's around two hundred fifty
dollars so we are a bit far from that
yes because all the prices look bigger
when you read them from right to left
really wasn't funny but that one you
should walk the plank
looking for more questions in the
moderator life house this morning the
cheapest chapel should I want me let's
see what we've got in the moderator
we've got did that one lorders we did
that one one way we expect a public
release of google play services yes
moving on wallpaper else is always city
it's definitely so wait were you looking
at the heterogeneous group do good you a
question I was afraid to there's one of
the deepest comments from Christopher
hair I'll be asking when if you can use
alternative paving modify this on google
play slow the answer is C the content
policy content policy says you must
always use to Google pay paper-plate
payment provider which is what except
for and it makes two exceptions the
first one is if you're paying for
physical goods so content tickets and
that's all right the opposite you can't
use google won't solos yeah then you
have to use your own pimp one and the
second one it says and I'm just going
from then weird if you will good buying
digital digital content which is
available beyond the application I think
the canonical example bears to look at
free like amazon mp3 for example we buy
access to an mp3 track and you can then
access a sec traffic well there on your
own and that's how the same for kindle
as well yeah you might read on here you
might read on your Kindle but it also
then says you must not use this to get
around using google play payment so you
constantly just decide you want to make
your digital assets whatever your just
point inside your game also available on
a website so that you don't have to use
our payment mechanism so it also comes
down to our policy teams and
interpretation of this of this fairly
nebulous description of the digital
content and available on I think the key
thing is if you're going to if the
primary use case is you're buying
something and you
in the application and always in the
application and there may be some other
method to access in the browser but you
know you can never expect when to use it
then that would climb consider that
trying to work around the policy and
that probably wouldn't be allowed so
those are two cases I know where you can
provide your own payment for a letter
but definitely it's always safest to use
Google Play how does hennas carry a
billing fit into that does that just to
come up as another option in google
wallet next to your credit card one
forty percent of Google Play users can
access carrier billing for all that in
many cultures the world's many operators
and yeah it just comes up as another
option cool same way that gift cards in
the US and if you buy a nexus 7 you have
this kind of balance that you get with
it so it's just come up as other options
which you can use the paper goods which
reminds me I think if you can buy nexus
7 do it very very soon i think the
original $25 credit promotion was
expiring at the end of sep tember so we
need to receive your Nexus 7 is it is
this a $25 only for us next 27 / so you
won right Germany all the official
countries that were supported got the
credit okay yeah yes my unit Red you
need to add the US credit card to get
those $25 though the UK was UK credit
card in 49 maybe in the UK UK killed it
that yeah well in the Nuge countries you
at your local country credit card you
get up yeah so what fine hair doctor
what if I here need a they ran yesterday
twice now right you got the replacement
Nexus 7 yeah I did it work twice yeah
let me show you just a second drop here
watch another one when I got the nexus 7
which is a pretty nice that I must admit
it 20 tonne X 07 well yeah well this one
is broken now you can see it really and
there is a nike plus there's the photo
with what's broken but I couldn't resist
I swapped the other covers ah
nice yeah yeah I have to I have to stay
with the white so we can do a break mine
is he still work up in the screen you
get it yeah it works the screen works
this is the broken one this green works
just broken and the touch doesn't work
all around the screen so i guess i like
it just you know maybe a nadie que
controller or a music stream here or
something it i'll make use of it well
you know they are starting to set in
Israel for us so so maybe they'll be
able to fix it for you very soon
actually there is there is a awesome
importers in Israel they provide service
to the NX seven right now actually
really well yeah and the international
warranty works so they accept it so that
that's very nice but then again I
couldn't resist i just got a new one
that's the nice thing about the low
price point isn't edited it almost comes
down to the oh what the heck I'll just
buy it level it makes it less painful
when it it's really cheap and knock
explains is the world they will know the
word you were looking for yet so where
did you buy it from directly from google
play if but from UK ous us hmm i got an
office there and cards and all that
stuff so I well I use other methods but
I'll not explain further day right don't
good oh and can I have another question
about some issue that I'm facing with
yeah I'm trying to do my own exception
catcher I have to catch all uncaught
exceptions so if my application will
crush what my applications never crash
but if will happen and it will crash
i'll be able to catch it and maybe
recover from it without without the user
noticing and all the stuff and if I
can't recover
I want to grab all the logs I want to
grab the system logs I want to grab my
own DB or something and send it over to
my crmserver um the thing that I've seen
is that when I have my own Handler and
which implements a uncaught exception
handler and I'm using the old school set
default uncaught exception my handler is
being cold when there is an exception
and I can run my code but for some
reason I either need to redraw the
exception and then android OS will kill
my application or I need to do
system.exit myself and kill the
application otherwise it looks like how
some reason the UI thread just get
stocks it doesn't go back to the event
loop or something I don't know so is
there a workaround around it or in such
a case I have to shut down my process
and we start it's probably worth saying
at this point jelly bean has tighter
restrictions on what logging information
you can access salary my logs only I
know I'm not looking for any other
application log I'm looking for my log
my own internal DB and sorry in advance
what I'm saving only my information you
mentioned the system look to your
thinking about accessing so if you're
okay without doing that right now I'm
simply reading a log that starting with
jelly bean i look at will show me only
my year my log lines and i'm fine with
it no prob then that that's great so how
are you going to know I mean I think
London and the bridge is falling again
or maybe not Oh we'll get London twice
here oh my god we shouldn't come back to
the studio but we didn't we've got a
black card but not in Thai studio just
like
yeah so you're trying to catch an
exception from somewhere in your
application how do you know you're going
to be able to recover from it without
having to kill the idea I can I first I
can query the application i can
understand which model had that that
exception maybe I can just restart that
models or maybe I cannot recover and I
have to shut down my application and
restart but in many cases I can recover
for example if the user presses a button
and for some reason I can't process that
event instead of crashing the
application i can just display a simple
toast message or a pop-up window saying
sorry we cannot do this
I think your app is just going to be in
a slightly unstable stage at that point
and uh the recommendation I think you
have to pass on either closely uptown
I'll pass it on to the default exception
handler to finish off cleaning up
because it zoomed that I mean that
you're not going to be able to recover
from this position if you thought that
the basic assumption that i'm not i
won't be able to recover and and this is
an only if you can deal with this
exception you should deal with it in the
place that it was originally caught and
carry on but you jumped from the main
thread now into the mentor has gone to
the exception handler and the exception
handler is now working we're just
logging this and killing the app so that
the system continued there is a tool
called a zero mobile connect which is
written by the guys at atlassian here in
Sydney which is an open-source thing
that does exactly what this guy's
talking about it kind of catches
exceptions and then lets the user kind
of leave a message for the develop stuff
and then that goes back and hooks into
JIRA the bug tracking tool and keeps
logs for your casket closed down right
it's just a little exception for it does
yeah when I know yeah yeah I used to use
a grinder again I'm just trying to
improve it and avoid having my
application yeah survive to do is log it
make sure you get the details of it in
Metro you catch it in the right place
next time just do an update to patch and
cat because as soon as the application
is is leaving its running state to go
into the exception handling state it's
on its way down I think I understand
default exception handler I mean that's
the thing which tears down right and
cleans a party I don't even hold on for
reference identical doing it after you
have to pass it on to do for exception
under once you've done to finish off all
clothes yourself I think the system
wants you to ah I gotta get the the
uncaught exception handler javadocs for
Android actually say it's only for
notification when the applications being
terminated I don't think there's any way
you can recover but what you might want
to think about is you could try using a
broadcast intends loop so in your
uncorks
epogen handler you could fire off a
broadcast intent have a broadcast intent
receiver which restarts a wrap yeah I'm
trying to do that but in some cases my
even my intent is not being broadcasted
roasting unless I kill my own process
I'm service to restart your up again um
I don't know why if we drop out more
frequently man she get three or four
about room in the grill at one time
right I don't know what all these drop
outs before that's why okay um change
the spark is still with us now they
dropped out one two three four five six
there's a follow-up question about the
payments in Google market knocking the
situation the guys given is if he has an
existing web based game and is
developing an android client for it
wants to allow people to purchase
digital goods for using that web based
game but via the Android app do you see
that as a loud or not I don't know if
you guys can actually answer that one or
whether you should just refer straight
to the Play Store guys yeah that's one
of the things I wish we were first place
what ways to get a definitive answer on
yeah comes down to whether it falls into
that definition shows digital content
isn't it which I'm on it thanks to warm
up yeah and if they think that the
majority of people are just you're
getting distribution through the Play
Store the majority of people are
installing the app from the Play Store
are getting the senior the Play Store
downloading it and only using on the
device then they may consider that how
the web version is a workaround and why
wouldn't you just you that up in up
payments to purchase those items anyway
why would you wanna work around it when
you're getting the distribution and the
extra users he sees thing is that his
primary existing game has already worked
web-based the Android app is an
extension to that so yeah I guess if you
can choose in that case not to have any
payments in it at all and then people
can buy the things on the way if they
want but he still shouldn't be back to
the web version to buy those things it
would be the safe option I mean if he
does do it the other way around and the
a-team decides it is infringing they can
just take it down well he can request a
support and go through the health
channels and ask for support and find a
ticket and I'm hopefully they'll make a
decision before he actually built the
end oh okay hello welcome back Sparky
there's between jelly I got more
dropouts them yeah it's it's not too
often that i did i lose my connection
here if you use much more often the case
that i simply can't make it in the first
place okay i just went up so you could
tell you pirate house you know you'll
find a set and today is only more quest
we won't go through in live in the room
or in the moderator did you answer any
questions in the moderator while I was
out and anything we were out as well we
just left the community up to it okay if
he's a quick question Nick when can I
see the next installment of your
redesign broadcast on YouTube well I'll
yeah so if those didn't know that we've
been doing a new show on Google purpose
live board and Android design in action
where we take a existing application
which is reviewed in the app clinic on a
Friday and give it a reimagining
applying the Android design principles
to it so you can tune in every tuesday
at three thirty gmt and and so yeah
they'll be back next week you watching i
do watch it I'm looking forward to I
particularly like the brown and orange
coloring to the stopwatch app this week
I've always tried to stick to close to
the hollow colors of using blue that's
quite cool to see something that drifted
a bit further apart neroni's a great job
when that I was beautiful yeah I think
he showed it a hipster blurry photo that
I had about 100 comments saying these
when i get the app right good designers
right when I all we should let him have
anything anything I reached on a
redesign of built-in storage but yeah
yeah since you guys didn't redesigned it
for me she's not yeah was that payback
for not implementing rich notifications
rich you'd i don't know i just took the
mick out of my name and then ignored the
rest of the app and i also wanted to
tell you an insight they started doing i
don't know in which language they do it
but they doing it abuse on startups on
google+ every wednesday at that's ido
ido brain is doing it yeah it doesn't do
it in English ok boo most of it is in
English like he'll be gonna be eighty
percent English twenty percent Hebrew he
took the first shot two weeks ago I
think so if anybody want
to watch it it's wednesday at two p.m.
is very time so that's basically silly
12 gmt or something like that we're
always game to you know the full you
know no scheduled program i go to
developers.google.com such lie there's
tons and tons of programming popping up
every day you busy right any other
questions are you coming to Israel again
i Richard said something then chill
about they're coming again in October
that was for another event allows me
come twitter at the same time but
unfortunately other event has been
canceled so i probably of you is around
in October but I have to get back before
the end of the year travel around Europe
it more as well the next things we will
be at droidcon london android com damn i
think we'll be attending by proposing um
but are you going to see I steadfast
isn't it we see what we can do in a most
I plan to work on other things but it's
always good to come out all right we'll
plan and and con on october twenty third
and and yeah we can't use droidcon here
so use and con now we won in june and
now we're gonna have another one in
october 23rd probably absolute are all
deities droidcon london's the 25th or
27th october so it'll be a busy week
yeah it might also be worth mentioning
that on developers.google.com / live if
you put / android after that you can get
just the android events yeah yeah so
what was that link again developers just
typing jeff google.com / live and he
won't just a session room put it in the
chat
yeah so unnecessary burning issues in
the room i think that we're in dissent
or about time today nothing going once
there's a couple of questions left in
the moderator but the either either i
don't know the answer or I've already
answered them and if the person who
asked the question wants us to talk
about it on the air than just let us
know offline and then we can copy the
questions over the next week or
something like that oh sorry about the
problem is about dropping in and out
today we'll try and find out what's
going back to the studio again next week
yeah this video quality were slick this
week we were in studio last week that
way when I don't know anyone in the
studio you've dropped a bit less than
what it used to be well well believe it
happened today video quality sings
little lower and bless particularly when
you move for me say hahaha is that
predicted yes yes scurvy dogs why are
pirates called Pirates it just are as
they not and on that I think you've sunk
the ship yes thanks enjoy yes and
Christians coming into the moderator for
next week and we will see you same time
next week thanks guys test